so I guess to start off with thanks
everyone for having me it's a real honor
to be here presenting at the final
strange Loop and at papers we love um I
do have a a long-running experience with
papers we love it's one of my favorite
Meetup series and so it's great to be
here talking with you um some of you
might have heard Andrew Black's talk
earlier this morning uh where he was
talking about why programming languages
matter um and you know kind of based on
Zan's introduction you might understand
that that was a little bit of a
preaching to the Quire moment for me I I
love programming languages I already you
know feel that they matter um but I
really took heart with one of his uh
quotes that he called out Alan pe's talk
or you know quotation about how learning
different kinds of programming languages
affects the way that we think uh and it
makes us better programmers right um so
I love programming languages I love
thinking about how they're similar to
each other how they're different from
each other different families of
programming languages how they can be
grouped together and so today I want to
talk about stack based languages which
is uh a family of languages that I think
are maybe less familiar to a lot of
developers out there um one that I think
is really important to be aware of at
least even if it's not something that
you're going to use in your day-to-day
programming um so I guess first off I
want to do a quick straw poll who here
knows or has heard of the language
fourth okay good that's basically
everyone in the audience for people
watching online um I saw somebody
walking around earlier with a Chuck
Moore t-shirt so I thought that there
would be at least one hit so that's good
um I don't I don't want to disappoint
this is actually not a talk about fourth
um it's not a talk about any real world
stack based programming language in
particular I want to talk about them as
a family I want to talk about the sort
of characteristics that they all have uh
and how they're all similar to each
other so there will be some mentions to
Fourth but it's not a fourth heavy talk
at all um and then lastly this is the
papers we love talk um so there's going
to be citations throughout I'm just
going to have like you know little you
know references on the slides as we go
through so that if I pique your interest
if this is something that you want to
learn more about there's plenty of
references to academic articles blog
posts books that kind of so that you can
learn
more okay uh so we have a lot to get
through so I'm going to go ahead and
jump in I apologize I'm going to try my
best to fit into the 40 minutes uh the
coffee break is next so if we spill into
the coffee break I apologize in advance
I'm going to do my
best um so I always feel like it's
easiest to learn about anything new but
especially a new kind of programming
language by comparing it to something
different from it especially if that's
something that you're already familiar
with so in the case of Stack based
languages I want to do a comparison into
more mainstream style languages which uh
are different than the sort of defining
characteristic of a stack based language
which is that they don't use names right
so the the defining characteristic of a
stack based language is that you don't
name the values that you're operating on
right so to see what that means I want
to take a look at a couple of languages
that do use names we'll we'll walk
through a couple of examples and then
compare what those examples look like in
a stack based language
instead so our running example is just
going to be uh right triangles in the
pyan theorem right so if you remember
back to your high school geometry you
know that the pyan theorem tells us how
we can calculate the length of a
hypotenuse from the length of the two
legs it's just some you know Square the
two numbers add them together take a
square root right um and this 345
triangle is the canonical example of a
right triangle that satisfies that
Pythagorean theorem but has nice
integral values for each of the three
sides right and this is a simple Python
program where we are using variables
again name right to sort of uh provide
the initial inputs the two legs of the
of the triangle and then we're just
walking through some arithmetic to
calculate the value of the hypotenuse
and if we evaluate this as you might
expect we get the answer five printed
out to the console okay now the 345
triangle is not the only one that has
nice integral values we've also got a 5
12 13 triangle so one thing we might
want to do with this program is abstract
that logic that computation into
something that we can apply more than
once um and in the case of python or
most other languages what that involves
is constructing a function where that
logic that we want to execute multiple
times is in the body of the function and
we use these named parameters to control
how we're evaluating at different times
with different
inputs um now in this case we're going
to step through the evaluation real
quick um because I want to sort of talk
about what happens you know sort of
internally in the execution state of
this program as we evaluate it so we're
going to start keeping track of these
things called environments or frames
which is keeping track of the names that
we're currently using in our program and
what values those names have and as we
start to step through you'll see that
the names that are being referred to in
the program start to appear in these
environments um and there's going to be
quite a few of them right because you
know actually in this case this math
module that we're importing itself is a
namespace and so that's also going to be
modeled by an environment frame and as
we go through and Define the function
that updates the frame which is tracking
the sort of file level scope and as we
start to invoke our functions we're
going to create new frames for each of
the invocations this is you know sort of
modeling the call stack at runtime and
as we step through the body of the
function you know the the frames grow
with new variables um when the
invocation finishes that frame gets
thrown away so that now when we invoke
it a second time we create a new frame
and start to track through its values as
we execute through um and eventually we
get to the end of this program where
we've printed out the five and the 13 as
we expect but in doing so we had a
fairly complex amount of state that we
had to keep track of um and we'll see as
we start to compare this with stack
based languages that's going to be
relevant to our
discussion okay um so we've seen how we
would model this example in a name based
language now we can start to look at the
same example in a stack based language
okay um so now the execution state for a
stack based language is going to be much
simpler so what we have here on the left
is a stack of values a program in this
stack based language is just going to be
a sequence of instructions not a tree
just a sort of linear sequence and we're
going to execute these instructions left
to right when we encounter an integer
literal what that's going to do is it's
going to push the value of that integer
onto the
stack and when we get to an operation
like this Plus for addition in a
language like python what we had to do
is we had to provide the specific values
that we wanted to add together in the
program text whereas here in the stack
based language this is implicit right so
the the values that we're going to add
together are whatever happened to be at
the top of the stack so in this case we
have one and two we're going to pop
those two values off add them together
and push the result back on okay so
fairly simple right it's just evaluate
left to right integer literals push on
most of these interesting operations
will pop things off the stack and then
push things back on in their
place we can look at a more complex
example now we're starting to get a
little bit closer to that Pythagorean
example that we looked at on the
previous slid
um so again we'll just step through this
we'll push the threes onto the stack
we'll multiply them together we'll push
the fours onto the stack multiply them
together add and then take the square
root and we've calculated the five
hypotenuse from that 345
train um and those of you of a certain
age like myself might recognize this as
reverse polish notation uh I think I
have to call these vintage calculators
now but like old school HP calculators
used this notation um just as part of
the operation of of the calculator so so
this is not like a fundamentally new
idea we've had it for quite some time
and it has some interesting
characteristics and benefits as we'll
see um now this example is not quite a
good translation of that first Python
program that we looked at because if
you'll notice what we have here is that
each of the legs we had to type the
value of that leg twice whereas in the
Python program we only had to do that
once we gave that value a name and that
name allowed us to refer to that that
value multiple times in the you know
remainder of our program in order to use
that value over and over again whereas
what we saw with our avaluation of the
stack program is that using a value when
for instance in in the Plus or times
operator consumes that value and so what
we had to do is we had to put it onto
the stack twice and refer to it you know
like explicitly by value twice in our
sour Source program so we want to avoid
doing that and to do that we'll have to
introduce some additional instructions
so here we see the new instructions dupe
and swap
and as we start to evaluate this we'll
see that dupe will take the value at the
top of the stack and push a copy of it
back on so here we only had to type the
number four in once but we were St still
able to use it multiple times um now we
can multiply it together we're going to
want to do the same thing to three but
dupe is going to uh duplicate the value
at top of Stack which is not where the
three is right now so we need to pull it
up to the top of the stack so that we
can operate on that's what this swap
instruction does it's going to take the
two values at the top of the stack and
reverse them so now the three is in the
right place so that we can duplicate it
Square it add the two together and take
the square root so now we actually have
a faithful translation I would say of
that first example Python
program okay so the next thing we did in
Python though is that we wanted to
perform that computation twice for the
two different triangles and to do that
in Python we abstracted over that logic
by creating a function and we're going
to do a similar thing here in the stack
base language
um and the abstraction in a stack based
language typically is signified by these
square brackets and it's called a
quotation typically um and then we also
had to add this new instruction called
apply and again we'll walk through the
evaluation here we push the three and
the four onto the stack the quotation is
an atomic thing it has like an arbitrary
amount of program text inside of it but
it is a single thing so when we evaluate
it we just push it onto the stack in its
entirety then when we get to the apply
instruction that's going to try to in
invoke one of these quotations right so
that's equivalent to function invocation
back on the python side so top of Stack
needs to be a quotation we're going to
remove uh the braces from it and we're
going to start evaluating it by taking
the content of the quotation and moving
it back over to the right side and now
we can proceed with evaluating like we
did before and we get the answer
five okay um so for that to work
remember the quotation had to be top of
Stack which meant that we had to push
things onto the stack in a particular
order for that to work what if we wanted
to do it in a different order we push
the quotation onto the stack we push the
three and the four we can't apply at
this point because quotation isn't at
top of Stack we can't use swap because
that would swap the three and the four
it can't see far enough down to where
the quotation is so again we're going to
have to introduce some new instructions
in this case we're going to introduce an
instruction called Dig Two uh the number
is telling how far down the stack it's
going to dig so you can imagine this is
a family of instructions they're could
be dig three dig four Etc it's going to
go to the value two elements down from
top of stack and it's going to bring it
up to the top of the stack and now the
quotation is in the right place so that
we can apply it and evaluate it just
like
before and now we have all of the pieces
in place to actually create the
translation into the stack language of
the second Python program where we
abstract over the logic and we invoke it
twice so we have the logic itself this
is the equivalent of the function
definition we have a sequence of
instructions that's going to invoke it
once for the 345 triangle and then
another chunk of instructions that will
invoke it for the 512 13
triangle and as we step through this we
push the quotation onto the stack here
we're going to want to apply that
quotation twice so this dupe is actually
duplicating the quotation itself right
because applying the quotation will
consume it we push the three and the
four parameters onto the stack the
quotation is not at top of Stack so we
have to take it up we apply and notice
here that applying the quotation doesn't
replace the program on the right hand
side it prepends the contents of the
quotation with whatever is still left to
be executed so that's kind of mimicking
the the sort of return stack in a
traditional language but we can go
through and execute the instructions and
we get to five the result of of that
first invocation um we've calculated it
we don't need it anymore so now we're
just going to drop that value on the
floor we're going to push the second set
of parameters on dig again apply again
go through math again and we got 13 as
we expect and then we can drop that on
the
flo okay so we have a stack language
we've seen how it relates to the name
based language that we started off with
we've seen our Pythagorean uh triangle
example in the stack based language and
we're starting to get a feel for how uh
the language pushes and pops and and
uses the stack as its its execution
State um so now we can start to talk
about some of the sort of like
interesting theoretical properties of
this language um and to start off with I
want to talk about what the meaning of
one of these programs
is um so what is the meaning of a stack
program right let's look at one that's
really really simple this is our one two
plus example and if you'll remember when
we evaluated this the end result is that
we pushed the the sum the number three
onto the
stack and it's important to call out
that this program doesn't require the
stack to be empty you can execute it
against a stack that already has values
on it and if you do those existing
values are left unchanged
so if we were to describe this in
English we could say that the meaning of
this program is that it pushes the
number three onto the stack and
importantly there are other programs
that have the same meaning right and you
could probably think of one just the
literal three right that would also push
three onto the stack and so in some
sense you could say that those two
programs are equivalent in meaning they
both have the same result on the stack
if you were to execute
them we can look at another example
where this one actually requires there
to be content already on the stack so
this is a a program that does dupe and
Then star um and so here the three
that's at the top of the stack will be
duplicated and then you know multiplied
and so the end effect is that we squared
that number at the top of the
stack or put another way we we pop a
value from the stack we Square it and
then we push the result
on okay now this is kind of hand wavy
this is an English language description
of the meaning we might want to get a
little bit more rigorous with this right
what is like a a more mathematical take
on on what the meaning of the program
is and so now we're going to get to one
of our first citations right so this is
looking at the factor programming
language um and what this is looking at
is a notation that's called stack
effects right so you can you can think
of the meaning of a stack program as the
effect that it has on the runtime stack
and this is actually a notation that was
first developed in fourth uh more as
like a documentation comment uh kind of
strategy whereas Factor took that and
turned into something much more more
like a type Checker where it could infer
stack effects from some programs and
verify that the the programs that you
type in uh have the effects that you
claim that they do um but the way that
this works is there's this Dash to the
left of the dash is the precondition or
what values are going to be consumed
from the stack by this program to the
right of the dash is the post condition
or the values that are going to be
pushed onto the stack and so in this
case the meaning of this program is that
it pushes three onto the stack it
doesn't consume anything and that's what
the stack effect for it looks
like for dupar right this one is going
to have something on the left hand side
as well because it does consume
something it's going to consume a value
X and it's going to push on x x x now
importantly this x x x is just a textual
label it's not actually any kind of deep
specification language it's not
verifying a mathematical property of
what you did it's just talking about the
shape of how you manipulated the stack
and so this stack effect is actually
entirely equivalent to just saying
results or anything else right it's not
doing anything deep with the meaning of
the program it's just talking about how
the shapes
change so we might want to think about
well is there a way that we can start
expressing these meanings in a way that
does talk about the actual specific
mathematical properties of what we're
doing um so we're going to start doing a
more mathematical definition of the
meaning of a program and here we're
building a lot on Manfred Von thun's
work on the joy programming
language um now to do a mathematical
treatment of the meaning of a program we
have to have a precise definition of the
program itself so let's start building
that up so to start with this is just a
a sort of math notation way of saying
that a program is a sequence of
instructions an instruction is either a
literal a built-in or a quotation where
a quotation is just another chunk of
program text in square
brackets the literals that we have in
this language well we only have integers
you might imagine that in a more
featureful language we might add things
like characters and strings and whatnot
but for our cases we just have integer
literals and the built-ins are the ones
that you've you've seen already some of
them do some arithmetic on those numbers
some of them manipulate the stack but
but these are the core instructions that
we have to work with in our
programs and given this definition the
meaning of a program which we use this
sort of chunky square bracket notation
for um is what we would call a stack
Transformer it's a mathematical function
that takes in a stack and produces a
stack and we're using this V hat
notation to Define Stacks so now we have
to sort of you know go a little bit
further what is a stack a stack is
either empty represented by this Epsilon
or it's a stack that has had a value
pushed onto
it and then a value in this language is
either an integer or a quotation and
it's important to call out here that the
integer values that appear on the stack
are not the same thing as the integer
literals that appear in the source code
like you'll notice maybe that I was
using very carefully a different font in
the earlier slides for them and here in
the mathematical notation it's it's
important to call out that the values
are like the actual mathematical concept
of the number itself whereas the
literals that appear in the source code
are just like sequences of
characters okay so given this we can
start to provide definitions of the
stack Transformers for each of the
instructions in our language so integer
literals we just push the corresponding
integer value onto the
stack uh for our arithmetic right we've
got an input stack on the left where we
expect there to be a certain number of
values we perform the calculation and we
push that onto the stack on the
output for quotations we just push the
quotation directly onto the stack
because if you remember those are Atomic
values so we just you know take it out
of the program text and put it onto the
runtime stack and then the apply
instruction expects the top of Stack to
be a quotation and it's going to take
the program text inside of that
quotation and apply it to the current
stack
and then lastly we have our stacked
manipulation instructions which are just
going to reorder values or copy them or
drop them right and you can sort of see
how each of them you know sort of have
the appropriate effect in their
definition of the left and right hand
sides
question uh that is digging the second
value below top of
Stack could be a dig three but I don't
need it for my examples and so but you
would treat them as distinct
instructions at least in the way that
I'm presenting it right now
yeah um so now we've done it for we
we've provided definitions for all of
the individual instructions so now what
do we do for a program which is a
sequence of instructions and if you
remember when we did this by hand
earlier in the slides we did it left to
right we we evaluated the instructions
left to right so we're going to do the
same thing here first we're going to
evaluate P1 against our input stack
and if you remember this is a
mathematical function if we apply the
function to an input stack what we get
is an output stack and so then that is
what we can apply P2
to so this is just saying that we
evaluate P1 and P2 in left to right
order whatever stack we get after
evaluating P1 is the state that we start
with when we start evaluating
P2 and so given these definitions we can
go through and verify that these simple
example programs that we were looking at
have the meaning that we were expecting
them to so one two plus if you'll
remember in English we said that means
push three onto the stack so we hope
that we can produce a definition that
looks like this we're going to carry
over some of our definitions from the
previous slide and now we're just going
to turn the crank first we evaluate the
first instruction which is one that
pushes a one onto the stack next we
evaluate the two that pushes the two
onto the stack then we evaluate the plus
which assumes that there's two numbers
at top of Stack pops them off and and
evaluates their their sum and then
pushes the result into the stack which
is what we were looking
for if we look at our second example
program again in English we want to pop
one value from the stack square it and
push the result back on um in a
mathematical notation it looks like this
we're going to need some more of the
definitions from the previous slide but
then again we're just turning the crank
evaluate dupe first that duplicates the
value at top of Stack evaluate star that
multiplies them together and that's what
we're looking
for okay um so we've talked about the
meaning of these programs like we've
convinced ourselves that we have a
mathematical interpretation that lines
up with what we expected when we were
sort of evaluating them by hand so now
we're going to talk about whether this
stack language that we're looking at is
complete and by that I mean turning
completeness right so this idea that any
computational process that you can think
of anything that can be expressed as an
algorithm
if our language is turning complete then
there is some stack language program
that we could write that implements
every single one of those computational
processes okay and to prove whether or
not a language is turning complete you
usually compare it against another
language that we already know is tur
complete and the canonical example that
you would start with is the Lambda
calculus um so if you haven't seen the
Lambda calculus before this is the
entirety of the language um like the
language just consists of Lambda
Expressions where you can think of a
Lambda expression as a function so this
is a function that takes in a value
which we'll call X and it's going to
return another function which takes in a
value Y and then it applies y to X and
this is all we have we don't have
anything else in this language and in
particular you notice we don't have
numbers or arithmetic or anything like
that like we had with our stack language
and that's okay that isn't this that is
not going to affect the completeness of
this language because there's this
clever thing called a church encoding uh
named after Alonzo church one of the
sort of forerunners of our theoretical
computer science background um and this
is a way of encoding numbers using just
Lambda calculus terms and if you haven't
seen this before the the notation can be
a little bit esoteric but intuitively
what this is encoding is that a number
is represented by a function that takes
in a function f and a value X and
applies F to that value the
corresponding number of times so zero
will apply F tox Zer times one will
apply it once two will apply it twice
and so there's a way of encoding like
numbers using this this pattern of of
building up later numbers from earlier
ones we're not really going to use this
encoding I just wanted to show it to say
that even though we don't have numbers
directly in the language like we can
simulate them and so that's not going to
affect the completeness of the
language um now normally we would sort
of say Lambda calculus is the basis
we're going to start with that one
because you know a century ago it was
proved to be Turing complete I'm going
to be a little little bit cheeky and say
actually we're going to start with the
one true mother language which is c um
and so this is a delightful little
project Lambda 8cc um it's an x86 C
compiler written in and targeting the
untyped Lambda calculus and this pull
quote from its read me is fantastic uh
it's long been known in computer science
that the Lambda calculus is trained
complete Lambda HCC demonstrates this in
a rather straightforward Way by showing
that c programs can be directly compiled
into Lambda calculus
terms yes really so they give an example
of this simple C program that calculates
the rot 13 encoding of an input and if
you run it through the compiler you get
this um or more accurately you get
something that this is the first of many
many many pages um but you can do it so
we can show that the Lambda calculus is
tur Complete because we can reduce it
from
C now having done so we actually have a
bit of a problem right so we went
through this first exercise where we
took took python which uses names and we
tried to turn it into the stack language
that doesn't but now we've gone back to
the Lambda calculus and we' brought
those names right back right and that's
maybe going to make it difficult as we
try to reduce the Lambda calculus
further to get to our stack language so
what we want to do is we want to see if
we can do this same process to the
Lambda calculus and get rid of the names
um and if you've been through this story
before you probably know that the answer
is that we need combinatory logic um
this is a fantastic book to mock a
mocking bird which goes into much much
more detail about this if you want to
learn more about it but the basic idea
is that we can Define this s k and I as
very carefully chosen Lambda terms and
the core thesis is that every single
Lambda term that you might possibly want
to write can be written in terms of
these three and moreover there's a
mechanistic process that you can use to
go from the land calculus term to its
its corresponding term in this ski
calculus and I'm not going to describe
it I'm just going to sort of show it in
action and as you go through you
eventually get to a definition on the
right the right is equivalent to the
left they are the same thing if you
wanted to go through and actually do the
expansion you could sort of see that it
works out to what you expect it to but
importantly on the right there are no
more names right SK and I in this word
sense are sort of like instructions or
Primitives in our stack based language
they're not names that refer to the
values that we're operating on and so
we've gotten back to a notation where
we've gotten rid of the names and we can
go a little bit further it turns out you
can write I in terms of SN K so we
actually don't even need I we can
actually rewrite every Lambda calculus
term into something that only uses SN K
and produces the same
answers okay so now given this I think
we can start to talk about whether the
stack language is turning
complete um it's actually almost turning
complete we're we're not quite there um
if you remember this is our definition
of what the language looks like we're
going to remove the numbers and the
arithmetic just like we have in the
Lambda calculus um we do have a church
encoding for numbers here uh it's quite
a bit longer and that's maybe some for
boing foreshadowing for what some of the
coming slides are going to look like um
again we're not going to use this we can
just know that it exists and so that
we're not losing out on expressiveness
by not having languages in the sorry
numbers in the core
language um so like I said it's almost
tur complete the issue is that we don't
quite have all of the instructions that
we need so we'll add a few more and now
we have something that is turning
complete how do we prove that it's
turning complete well we're going to
take S and K and we're going to write
out a stack language equivalent for each
of them again I'm not going to work
through the proof that these are
actually equivalent you can do that at
home if you want to um but having done
so we can now take the Lambda term that
we had already translated into the SK
calculus we're going to use that third
line to change all of the parentheses
into square brackets and you'll notice
that as we did so we actually reversed
the order of the s's in the ks and then
we're just going to substitute and we
get this uh it's big it's hairy it's not
something that you would ever want to
write directly uh but it is equivalent
to the same Lambda term that's there on
the
left and so what we've done now is we've
shown that that stack language is
turning complete by a multi-step
reduction from again the mother language
C
okay
but can we go
further so you'll remember with the ski
calculus we noticed that we didn't need
that I we were able to rewrite I in
terms of SN K and have a language that
was still complete but with a fewer
number of primitive pieces so we're
going to see if we can do that with our
stack language as
well um and so to start with you know
like the the set of instructions that
we've been building up has been getting
more and more which is like the opposite
of minimalism um but what we can do is
we can start to to categorize them and
it turns out that there's six important
categories here in these instructions
there are some instructions that unquote
they remove a layer of quotation there
are some that add a layer of
quotation there are some that
concatenate the contents of two
quotations together there are some that
reorder values on the stack and then we
have one instruction that destroys a
value and another instruction that
copies the value and you notice those
last two we only had one instruction for
that category so we're actually going to
yet again add a couple more so that now
we can say that we have at least two
instructions that do each of those six
categories we now have two that can do
destroy and we've actually got four now
that we can do that do a copy Okay so
we've got those six categories each of
these instructions do one or more of
those things you know sort of
fundamentally um and where that starts
to help us is that we can actually
Define every single one of these
instructions in terms of the other ones
right so just like we could Define I in
terms ofk for every single one of these
stack instructions that we've been
looking at there is some definition in
terms of the other ones that we could
come up with they're they're they're not
obvious they're you would have to spend
some time working through the algebra to
make sure that they're equivalent but I
contend that they are so let's keep
going and so now we need to choose some
of these as primitive and then we know
that with these definitions all of the
other ones we can Define in terms of
those Primitives almost as like a
syntactic sugar kind of thing so most
commonly you'll see these six chosen as
the ones that are primitive and there's
a reason for that it's that each of
these instructions only do the category
that they belong to apply only unques it
doesn't do anything else compose only
concatenates it doesn't do anything else
and so on and so these six are sort of
like a nice conceptually elegant set of
Primitives because each one of them has
like a one toone correspondence with
those
categories but we can choose other ones
so we might choose cons Sip and K for
instance and what's important is we just
have to make sure we choose Primitives
that ensure that all six of those
categories are covered and if so you've
got a complete basis in this case we
actually have uh covered unquote twice
so this is maybe not the most elegant um
Brent Kirby in in the blog post that a
lot of this is drawn from proposes cake
and K as the basis which is most elegant
and what this is is that there's only
two Primitives they cover all six of the
uh categories and none of the categories
are repeated and so this is sort of a
nice elegant base um again apologies in
advance we're going to show that this
actually works with just Kake and K by
doing a substitution and it looks like
this uh so we were able to build up this
Lambda
term using only quotation cake and K and
I absolutely am not suggesting that you
go home and start writing your PHP
websites in this notation or anything
like that but you
could all right uh and so then now we
have our our sort of like final
completeness uh proof where we go all
the way through to this cake language
and it's all Turing
complete okay last bit of math before we
start to play around with gadgets is
associativity um so I want to go back
and look at this definition that we had
for evaluating a sequence of
instructions right and if you remember
back to your high school algebra you
might recognize this as the definition
of function
composition and this this this this is I
think the key idea from Von thun's work
and so I'm even going to put some
flashing red lights next to it on the
slide right um and I'm just going to
read it out loud syntactic concatenation
is semantic composition the two are
equivalent they are the same thing
syntactic concatenation means we've got
the text of our program and we're just
gluing pieces together we're not doing
anything smart we are just literally
doing string concatenation of the
programs and if we do that on the right
hand side where we've got this more
mathematical interpretation it's just
function composition we had these stack
Transformers that are functions we
compose them together and we get the
interpretation of a larger program from
the interpretation of its smaller
pieces this is a key Insight it's really
really important um to see why it's
important I want to look very briefly at
a program that has more than just two
elements in it right um here we have to
choose how we're going to parenthesize
this right so we could parenthesize it
like this and then if we use our
definitions we just sort of Step through
and we get this answer on the right
where the parentheses that were on the
left in some way sort of carry through
and are also there on the right but we
could have parenthesized it differently
and we end up with again the sort of
corresponding parentheses on the right
but what's really important to recognize
is that concatenation on the left in our
program syntax and function composition
on the right are both associative we can
parenthesize them however we want and
we're going to get the same result at
the
end and I want want to call out a couple
of things that this is not saying right
this is not saying that we're changing
the order that we're executing our
instructions we're still executing
everything left to right so we're
talking about associativity not
commutativity the other thing that this
is not saying right is if you remember
back we were doing arithmetic that
involves things like plus and times and
those operations are themselves
associative right you can have an
arbitrary you know tree of pluses and it
doesn't matter the way that you
parenthesize them you get the same
result that's not what this is talking
about right again we're doing a specific
sequence of pluses in a particular order
with a particular you know uh uh
parenthesize what this is saying is that
we can pull parts of that out and
pre-compute them in any order and once
we build those pieces back up together
we get the same result it's maybe a
little bit hard to track so let's
actually look at what this concretely
gives us as a benefit associativity is
great because if you have associativity
it lets you do parallelism like
executing your program in parallel to
gain speed right um so now let's look at
one last interpretation of our stack
language where we're actually compiling
it into assembly um and in this case
we're compiling it into x86 assembly
we're using the x86 stack as the runtime
stack that we were simulating on our
slides and so there's a direct
translation of every instruction into a
snippet of assembly
code and in this world to interpret a a
program we just take the assembly chunks
for each instruction
and concatenate them together and so
this concatenation on the right is
associative in the same way that
function composition was on our previous
slides so now we're going to take
advantage of this we're going to take
this example program very briefly we're
going to expand a couple of those
numbers into some calculations just to
give us something a little bit more
meaty to play around with and then we're
going to divide this program up into
pieces and importantly it doesn't matter
where we break this up we can choose any
division point that we want and we're
going to comp compile each of those
colored sections independently and in
parallel and that gives us a chunk of
assembly for each one and then to get
the assembly the compilation result of
the overall program we just glue them
together and so this concatenative of
the language the associativity of this
compiled representation that we came up
with is what lets us take advantage of
that associativity and get this
parallelism for free with our
language okay uh so now in my remaining
I think three minutes left we'll be able
to talk about a real world uh stacked
language um I'm going to look at uxn um
if you are not familiar with this I very
very much recommend you check this out
it's a fantastic little project um deine
who is one of the members of 100 rabbits
who came up with this is speaking
tomorrow about the sort of like uh
permac Computing e permac Computing
ethos that led to this language it's
it's it's amazing it's a real stack
based language um the virtual machine
that that it specifies has also access
to like a main memory a fixed size main
memory and the ability to interact with
IO devices but the core like arithmetic
the ALU part of it is is stack based in
exactly the way that we've been looking
at and I'm not going to give you a lot
of detail on like the content of uxn
partly because of time but also because
there's a fantastic set of resources out
on the web there's a really nice
thriving Community there are great uh
reference documentations for the
language itself and for the VM there are
great tutorials about how to get up to
speed on programming in this language uh
so instead we're just going to look at
some of them running um so for instance
we've got a snake program right if you
remember this from qbasic days or
anything like that and you'll notice
that my adrenaline means that I'm not
playing it nearly as well as I would
like but you know you can play
it um there's
also you know just some nice you know
demonstrations of the graphic
capabilities there's a
clock there's a cat
clock right uh and there's
pong
right kind
of I'm not sure if that's I'm not sure
if that's talking about my ability to
play or the the artifact oh oh you guys
got it okay good um so yeah so like this
is an emulator running the uxn you know
scheme on my laptop here just you know
using x windows and everything uh but I
do also have it running
on this little pie badge that I brought
right uh sorry for the glare I'm going
to try to move it around so this is that
same tile example that we looked at you
notice that the uh frames per second is
much lower am I pressing the right
buttons let's reset
it here we
go right so it's again sorry for the
glare but you know like it's it's
working um if
I load other ROMs onto this device we
can play other ones as
well let's see
sorry what do you think should we do
snake next yeah let's do snake that was
autoc completed so I think that's the
right one to do so back to the camera
this one's going to be very hard to play
in Reverse but I'm going to try my best
nope that's the wrong
way ah I did it again
right not very good at it I wasn't very
good at it on the laptop so it I guess
stands to Reas that I'm going to be even
worse at it on the uh the camera but
there we
go so wrapping up wrapping up um I think
the main thing I want to sort of be the
takeaway message is that you know stack
bases languages are interesting they're
conceptually simple maybe some of those
cake K examples maybe betrays that it's
not as simple as you might think but
like you know conceptually it's simple
not just for interpreting it sort of
mathematically theoretically it also
means that it lends itself well to you
know sort of implementation especially
on constraint devices and stuff like
that so with that thanks very much for
your
[Applause]
time